[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and it's time to
put a smile on that face with the
release of Joker now creating a new wave
of comic-book crime terror across the
world Joker is a riot literally and the
film has a lot to unpack from both its
plot and ending throughout this video
I'm going to be breaking down everything
that you need to know about the movie as
well as what we can take from its
overall premise and the final few scenes
now there will be heavy spoilers here so
if you haven't seen Joker yet and don't
want to have anything about the movie
potentially ruined then I highly
recommend that you turn off now without
the way I just want to give a huge thank
you for clicking this video now let's
get into our breakdown of Joker Joker
follows the story of Arthur Fleck a man
who has literally been dealt a bad card
in life and seems to be the Joker in the
pack in every situation black has severe
mental health issues that cause
uncontrollable laughter and the
character lives on the poverty line
struggling to get by day to day he cares
for his mother who like him suffers from
delusions and dreams of becoming a
comedian in order to escape his life of
unhappiness
unfortunately for flack he lives in
Gotham City a town that pretty much
makes the rich get richer and the poor
get poorer so when he's told fantasies
that he's the illegitimate son of
Gotham's wealthiest citizen Thomas Wayne
naturally his mind starts to wander he
seemingly forms a relationship becomes a
viral laughingstock stops taking his
meds and causes an uprising in Gotham
that leads to the death of several of
its richest people including its first
family the Wayne's though the film isn't
set in modern day it certainly tackles a
lot of modern-day issues such as cuts to
medical and social care and it basically
builds a world in which circumstances
are right for a character like the Joker
to emerge this is highly relatable to
modern-day society in which there seems
to be more and more lone Wolf's carrying
out attacks on people on mass and it
forces us to ask ourselves are these
just bad apples or is society structured
in a way that creates such monsters
Joker also demonstrate
mental health issues on a respectable
level due to the fact that we find out
the character was abused and due to his
conditions smiled through the majority
of it often when dealing with depression
many people are told to put on a happy
face and in cases like the death of
Robin Williams
we know that the actor outwardly
appeared very happy when there was
clearly things going on beneath the
surface
anyway Joker wants to terror all down
and show Gotham its ugly face and now
the film is receiving a lot of
controversy for its depictions of the
character citing that he may inspire
further attacks I personally believe
that the film is actually a warning that
we had to change things on a fundamental
level before this becomes more
commonplace his desperation to find
answers to his problems is mirrored in
the actions of the citizens of Gotham
who slowly began to follow the Joker's
acts and caused an uprising in the city
the violence is crazy
Joker kills people that attack him his
own mother and many more in some
disturbing moments the movie really
ramps up to the Murray Franklin show
scene which stands out is scary on a
number of levels if you've seen the Dark
Knight Returns then you know what to
expect in that but even with prior
knowledge it still packs a hell of a
punch the ending is also almost the same
as Batman Begins with the mad citizens
of Gotham and tearing down the city from
the inside however instead of a toxic
gas that causes them to do this Joker
uses the notion of an idea as its
trigger to send Gotham into chaos as
mentioned earlier we see the Wayne's
including a young Bruce go into the
infamous Crime Alley and watch their
deaths at the hands of Joker's new
movement whilst it's a depiction that
we've seen play out countless times
before here it holds a lot more weight
because unlike prior entries we've seen
the film build up to the point where the
death of one of the city's most
wealthiest citizens seems like a natural
conclusion this also adds more nuance to
the Batman origin itself as Bruce now
lives in a world where his parents
deaths were in some form erna they're
caused by the Joker
Bruce has witnessed firsthand how an
idea can inspire people to do bad and
therefore we can understand why he
eventually becomes a symbol for good the
fact that their deaths are because of
the Joker in some form gives reason to
why he would decide to Don a mask in
order to take down criminals and it
really can't be overstated how much this
movie flashes out his reasoning
what we've seen before similar to Joker
Bruce becomes a product of Gotham but
unlike Arthur Bruce decides to go the
opposite way potentially because of his
money and resources and they pretty much
become two sides of the same coin whilst
this growth into the Dark Knight doesn't
necessarily happen in the film I think
that the piece is laced with enough
subtext to the point that it allows the
viewers to work things out for
themselves and that truly is the triumph
of Joker's throughout the film it laces
seeds as to what is happening so that
the audience members can draw their own
conclusions come up with their own
interpretations and also decide who what
where and why happened the way that they
did it's a really smart move and no
doubt viewers will all take something
different away from the film each time
that they watch it now the thing that
you have to know from the beginning in
order to truly understand Joker is that
Arthur is an unreliable narrator many of
the events that we see in the film
including attending him that they may
all be in the characters head and while
some definitely do happen others don't
we know that flack imagines himself on
the Murray Franklin show that his
relationships on the way that he
perceives them and there's some
questions over the entire movie that
leaves love ambiguity to everything he's
not related to the Wayne's he's not
dating his neighbor and he might in fact
be trapped in the Marvel Universe that's
that's a joke by the way that's a joke
anyway there's some big similarities to
Fight Club in this film with a
protagonist going from a lowly member of
society to becoming someone that takes
it down by the film's clothes like that
movie we see things from the main
character's perspective rather than
those around him therefore it's
difficult to justify whether what
happened is truly the way that things
played out and the movie deliberately
ends ambiguously in order to form a
discussion as to whether Joker is the
city's biggest super villain or just a
legend in his own mind this of course
carries forth motions of the Alan Moore
graphic novel which apparently tells the
characters origins though he does stay
in that that he prefers to leave a
multiple choice and nose like myself who
prefer that the Joker's origin remains a
mystery are able to have their cake and
eat it on this one either way this is a
city that has been completely torn apart
Khaos the film ends with the character
in Arkham being interviewed and we
really get the feeling that his reign of
terror will continue even from beyond
the bars of the infamous Asylum as he
runs along the corridor to send in the
clowns now I do believe that some of the
events in the film happen and some
didn't but I guarantee that there will
never be a concrete answer and because
of this the movie will be discussed for
decades Joker at one point draws a smile
on his face in blood and this really
symbolizes that blood had to be shed in
order to make him happy and he achieved
this so now Joker has found something to
give him a purpose this of course is a
reference to the graphic novel
flashpoint in which the Joker of that
universe carries out something similar
and it hammers home just how much
society is slowly sending everybody
crazy as a whole Joker is a masterpiece
I know that the movie already has some
detractors but this really is an
oscar-worthy performance by Joaquin
Phoenix who completely knocks it out of
the park with his betrayal of the Clown
Prince of Crime it's a shame that the
media has basically turned into the
real-life version of the woman from The
Simpsons who keeps saying won't somebody
please think of the children because it
packs a lot of commentary on modern day
society and in my opinion it deserves to
be seen whether you think you like or
dislike the subject matter
Joker really is incredible and it's a
unique film that I truly believe will
stand the test of time at the moment I'm
in two minds over whether this is better
than endgame or not but either way 2019
has been an incredible year for comic
book movies with this pretty much being
the cherry on top
Joker requires your attention and I
really can't recommend it any higher I
can't remember the last time or if I've
ever given a ten out of ten to a film on
this channel
however this deserves it it's a true
reflection of our time and really should
be required watching for any fans of
Batman DC or comics in general
congratulations DC todd phillips joaquin
phoenix and all of those involved in the
making of this you absolutely smashed it
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the film and if you agree
with me or not comment below and let me
know and if you enjoy this video then
please like it and make sure you check
out my breakdown of the behind the
scenes sepharose a black widow that
confirmed that part of the film will be
after the events of Avengers endgame a
breakdown all of the images and give my
theories on it so make sure you watch it
after this if you want to come chat to
me about movies TV shows games and comic
books and make sure you follow me on
twitter at definition whitey it's the
best way to get in touch with me and
it's the perfect place to suggest new
videos and content so hopefully I see
you over there after this also just want
to let you know that we're currently
giving away a free copy of spider-man
far from home on blu-ray and all you
have to do to be in with the chance of
winning is to like this video make sure
that you subscribe to the channel and
leave your thoughts and Joker in the
comment section below
the winner will be chosen at random on
October the 15th and the blu-ray will be
shipped out from mentor but gets the
prize it's the best of luck to everyone
who takes part this is a channel for
people who are super into superheroes so
if that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this I've been definition
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time take care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]